already shirt off
style
yeah it's always already
here this
what is
sought
fulfillment
Freedom
wholeness
Perfection unconditional love all of
that is this here
already
and it's hidden by the pursuit of
finding
it seeking hides the Fulfillment that it
already
is
it's Beyond
Simple it's super
ordinary
this just this
already doesn't
matter what it's appearing
as just this already
yes in the live chat this is it wanting
to know this is this having the
experience that there is something
else
unknowing wanting to
know
is the same this
sing there's nowhere to
go full
Checkmate
full end of
seeking
full dissolution of satisfied Center
Point looking for
knowing yeah there's no
chance there's no chance
that what already is can be
found yes after so many years of seeking
and running after different types of
meditations that came across this
message and and it was huge
relief spot
on
yes nowhere to
go no one to go
anywhere
it's great that apparent
story of a
Seeker
that was seen to be an
Illusion by no
one even that story itself
is not worth
mentioning and it's all of the spiritual
discourses
are all about mes that are on spiritual
Journeys and so when
it hits this wall of no story no Journey
already
fulfillment it is a huge
relief
it is a huge
relief because there's endless types of
meditations there endless experiences
it's endless
books endless
teachings one of the favorite questions
that this has been
asking those that it encounters that are
on spiritual Journeys
is
what are you seeking what are you what
are you looking
for have you ever met anyone that said
that they found what they were looking
for have you ever met someone
that have you ever met someone that said
that there wasn't a you or
that ask you if they're e even was a
real
you has it has there ever been a
consideration that there isn't
separation to overcome in the first
place that there isn't even an
entity there in the first
place that there are no individuals in
the first
place yeah these questions
get more and more
undermining the seeker and cutting the
duality of
the
Seeker and it's it's
beautiful
yeah
I put on a shirt I can't take it oh let
Let Me Wait I need to change
the there we go okay now you can now you
can see my my
nipples
yes there we go much
better how can there even be a
discussion on the subject of nonduality
without nipple
rubs
impossible
another
really fun response to the seeking
energy is just woof woof
woof
[Music]
mooo
meow
[Music]
meow just undermining
it with what is a reflection of just
natural wordless
wholeness
innocence
emptiness the word already is very
powerful it doesn't allow
any wiggle
[Music]
room for it to not be
already what is longed
for already is the perfect word to
undermine the
Seeker unknowing is also a very powerful
undermining
word and it's always
that
yeah so much of this is
just nowhere to go nothing to say no one
to say it no one to hear
it dawing is very
effortless basic needs abundance
Prosperity
play
only in that stinky Little Pond of me is
that not
obvious the whole function of the
body when there's that
me is about what it can
get and when it's no longer there and it
never
was then it's about the
hole because there's only
that
there's a comment about the about the
hair and about it getting
lasered
no I love
this there's so much
cherishing of this
yeah yes there's no way around it
being what
is
yes
Same
Love yeah there's there's
[Music]
so you there's
both endless riffing and then there's
nothing to
say it's obviously already this and
there's nowhere to go cuz everything is
it and there's no way to get closer to
it or further from it it can't be lost
it can't be
found it's already no one everything
thinging it's already that it's already
non-local it's already
nothing and it's already not
lost so then it can't be attained if
it's not lost it can't be
attained already means not
lost already means never
lost switch it up a bit put the guest
camera up over here so we got two angles
on this
side
yeah
not
to leaves
no room
for any kind of
two it doesn't leave any room
for it not being
already
so obviously that's very annoying
to me which lives
in
duality
and it's just all unconditional love so
even me that
is in its cloud of
knowing
just seeking more
experiences and just pinballing between
Concepts and is and trying to get
validated for how much it knows and how
smart and worthy it is even that is
unconditional
love appearing as
that and there's no value structure it's
not saying that that is better or worse
cuz that would again be a
duality
there's nothing to say about the already
nature of it the already nature is
ineffably appearing as
everything no matter what's appearing
it's
that it's wholeness already Perfection
already Freedom already appearing as
whatever is arising and that's
Freedom that's freedom
it's not something that will be gotten
later it's what the nature of everything
already always
is the ising itself is
wholeness it's Freedom
love
The Emptiness of there not being an
entity of there not being a subject of
there not being a me or an individual is
in fact the
wholeness is the
Fulfillment that is
sought but me or the
individual it can't
[Music]
imagine a reality without
it but wholeness is the absence of me it
is the absence of the
individual it's the freedom of
non-local
unity a position locationless Unity
and there's all kinds of things that
still get attached
to all kinds of traditions and wisdoms
and practices and
[Music]
paths
manifestations
and
teachings
mystical traditions and all kinds of
things that get attached to and all of
those dissolve nothing
remains nothing
remains all of the attachments are just
seen as
boxes bounds
identities even Dow itself is just what
this body naturally spontaneously
appears to do how it appears to
be and everything is that everything is
that Natural Body spontaneity
and then there's a
contracted
appropriation that
arises that is
me that lacks and needs and wants to
know and tries to box and bound and
control and manipulate the appearance in
the way that it
dualistically desires for it to be and
so then it tells people oh which are non
entities so it's telling no one it's no
one telling no one oh well you should be
this way you should behave this way you
should think this
way you should side with
this
group
yeah yeah
when me is no longer not only is it seen
that it never was but there's
a impossible to to
describe freshness and
newness and aliveness and
rawness
unfiltered
intimacy with
everything as
everything
me is always manipulating or controlling
the
appearance to get something out of
it which is
usually validate
me for how much I
know
for how smart I am for how good of a a
boy or girl or man or woman I
am validate my separate existence
validate my
individuality validate the gold stars
that I've
attained in the conceptual elaborations
are just endless endless endless
conceptual elaborations on all kinds of
things and there's even there's even a
conceptual elaboration of what Emptiness
is and it's obviously not it because
there's still an individual there
apparently so me even knows how to
hijack
emptiness and then say no or I know what
that
[Music]
is
no there wouldn't be a you and there
wouldn't be
knowing and there wouldn't be seeking
nor would there be manipulating
appearance to try to be valid validated
if there was actually no
one and that's just how the field morphs
that's how the cookie crumbles
how how the boundless
apparently
energetically contracts into its me
Distortion which is obviously still
unconditional
love undergoing that
appearance yeah none of this can
actually
be ever
said yeah imagine trying to take
what can't be said or the ineffable and
trying to say what it is can't say what
everything
is and
so not to is one of the closest ways to
say what everything
is and all ready is a great way to say
it unknowing is a great way to say
it
emptiness
wholeness unconditional love
freedom it's just too free to be talked
about
it's too
free it's so free that anything can
happen anything can
appear no can appear as
anything and so that's how free it
is
when no thing is appearing as
me how me appears is lack
need and when no is appearing as
everything it's Dow
it's
hessing and that's really the only thing
that you can say about
it is it's
all
undifferentiated and when there is that
bodily contraction of
separation and of lack and
need then
that appears
as an
insatiable
knowing an insatiable meing or
selfing
wholeness is appearing as that and
wholeness when it's not appearing as
that is obviously no thing
everything and therefore doesn't have
that lack
need manipulating the
appearance for insatiable
knowing trying to get something that's
not
missing
yeah the knee-jerk reaction of the mind
is to feel figure everything
out yes me wants the appearance to be a
certain way it's
not satisfied with the appearance and it
wants it to be a certain
way and so it will grab and control and
twist everything until it gets its way
and it doesn't matter what how it has to
grab
twist so if if it has to take others
and enslave
them it will because it doesn't
care it wants to be validated as kingly
or
queenly and so being a a ruler of a
nation state or a massive
Corporation it doesn't care about others
it doesn't care about the way that it
treats those that are beneath them just
doesn't
care is that boundless Energy's
contracted into a center point and that
Center Point cares about
itself and then it cares about its
family and then it cares about its
company or its nation state and then it
cares about how it's perceived how that
Center Point that's an illusion is
perceived by elusory
others and so if it has to manipulate
Other Nation States if it has to pillage
their resources if it has to enslave
their
people if it has to
offer very very low egregiously low
paying
work if it has to not give any benefits
to those
workers it just if it doesn't give any
shares or inclusive stakeholding of the
projects that are being created it just
doesn't care it doesn't care me is the
most
aggressively dissatisfied energy
imaginable it's so aggressively
dissatisfied that it
will take every single precaution ction
imaginable to maintain its Center
poess to maintain that strong contracted
identity because I am good I am real I
am
smart my people are better than your
people and if we have to drop bombs on
your people We Will We Will pillage your
resources we will write contracts that
favor our people because your people are
less than my
people and so all of that is completely
made of unconditional love all of that's
completely Ely no one or nothing
undergoing that
crazy beautiful ucer contractive
dance
and
this stream is about already and there
will be another upcoming stream about
all of that
what has been called separation porn
which is this main way that this no
thing
apparently gets lost
in war and all
the separation
porn
and it's never lost it's always
perfect but that's one of the best ways
to be able to describe what it
is because it's a bunch of stinky
ponds of me that are projecting others
and fighting against
them and then there's a bunch
of people on the Internet or wherever
non- entities that are
watching eating popcorn and oh look at
this separation porn which side do you
want to pick Let's retweet about which
side is better than the other
side yeah and all of that
completely hides
this it just totally hides
it separation is never actually
there it's always nonpar it's always
wholeness it's always
non-local and then
this this
crazy ability miraculous really ability
for something that's non-local to
contract itself into an elusory Center
Point that then projects
others that then it then
fights that's the most psychedelic thing
imaginable that's the trippiest thing
imaginable that that's
possible something that's obviously
nothing
everything
that's obviously a singularity it's
obviously a unified wholeness that is
non-local that is non-
entity somehow
that can contract into the experience in
the body of uh I'm separate and unho and
that's other that I must kill
much love back at yeah in the live
chat
so
yeah yeah this is this is the
thing what is
speaking and what is
hearing is
perfect it's
non-local it's unconditionally
free and it's
already and there's nowhere to go from
that there's nowhere to go as
that that is the Alpha and
Omega it's
beginningless and endlessness it's
that and it's
already it's
already these
streams
that's the that's the T
emoji let's
go these are great
nice
it's already
nothing there's nowhere to
go it's already
nothing
it's already
free it's already
wholeness it can never not
be
it's great it's it just an absolute
cessation
of anything to say
there nothing to say there's no one
saying it there's no one hearing it it's
just perfect Freedom itself what is
always sought is this here everywhere in
knowing forever Perfection it's
so incredibly simple ordinary and
awesome
h
H yeah there it
is
yeah
it's just so
perfect so
simple and it's crazy spontaneous wild
bouncy and free as
[__]
so whatever is
[Music]
appearing
wow just
wow
it's just impossible for anything to not
be unconditional love and
freedom everything is always
unconditional love and freedom
everything is always no
one what can you do with that where can
you go with that
nowhere
so this is completely
intention it's just spontaneous sharing
and it seems to be a response
to what the appearan
is Waring and in separation poring of
All Sorts in New Age spirituality of All
Sorts seeking his asss off
fighting and so this is just the a
response this is a response to that in
the appearance and it's
a it's a response that there's only no
thing everything and that from
that wholeness is Dess it's
Dow it's decentralizing basic needs play
fun Prosperity abundance for
all
and it's just wildly simple it's wildly
wildly simple there's no extra complex
elaborations there's no complex rights
or rituals or therapies or initiations
or experiences or attainments or coaches
or gurus or
manifestations or trauma work or healing
or psychedelics or meditations or breath
works there's none of those complex
things here here is just the simple
response that there is no individual
there is no me there is no Center Point
there's only nothing everything and as
long as there is a Center Point as long
as there is that ucer assumption and
contracted belief and
knowing as long as that's there there
will be others there will be War there
will be separation there will be seeking
wholeness or seeking fulfillment in
Endless kinds of ways and that is simply
mutually assured destruction here in
this apparent real and unreal
Earth there's nothing more to say about
it there's dawing and there's meing and
that's all there is and those the
appearance of that being two is actually
obviously one it's all obviously nothing
nothing naturally Dows and it in
contraction it
mes that's it it's nothing else to
say there's nothing else to
say
it's so obvious as long as there's me as
long as there's Center Point it will
always be about me it will always be
about the center point okay when that
Center Point is clearly seen by No One
by nothing that it's an illusion and it
isn't it doesn't exist it's not actually
there then it's obvious that wholeness
or dawing is the natural spontaneous
movement of the body in the
appearance
yeah it's just it's just
fascinating ribbit ribbit ribbit ribbit
ribbit ribbit
ribit you send uh emojis in the live
chat and I'll do my best to make some
sort of
artistic representation of
them we just got a frog
obviously imagine if we got a bear and I
did all that frog
stuff that' be so
funny
hey
in the meanwhile we should definitely
get another
uh let's do that and then let's get a
zoom out yeah so we can get a nice
little nipple session going in the
meanwhile nipple session yeah yeah yeah
uh uh nipple session yeah yeah yeah uh
uh nipples yeah yeah
arola on the
nipples AR arola on the nipples yeah
yeah
arola on the
nipples
[Music]
woo
yeah flick them flick them flick those
nips flick them flick them flick them oh
damn that's that's those are
hard
oh that's
good okay that was our nipple
session he so fun on the on the news of
the local
community it just cuts from the weather
to to a 60-second nipple session where
there's just the Ring of the
nips see we're doing civilization all
wrong should have the minute long nipple
hour minute long nipple
segment absolutely nothing is
serious nothing at all is
serious
how could this be
serious I
mean nothing when it's in its elusory
contraction Waring against
itself
is obviously
serious but nothing is obviously
ridiculous it's it's so
ridiculous it's so
innocent it's so innocent
that and
free that and already that
there's the
ridiculous appearance of what that
innocent free already Readiness can
appear as which
is serious war and hating of
others all the way
to
incredible uh burgers
and
Sushi
and flights across the
planet that's why there's such a draw in
a way to comedy at least here there's
such a draw to Comedy and there's so
much excitement there was just today
there was a a messaging of a lot of of a
lot of well-known comedians inviting
them on to the
podcast
and I'm just imagining sitting like this
with Bert Bert ker you know that kind of
stuff just
um
like and just it just reminds me so much
the comedic side the comedy reminds me
so much of nothingness it reminds me so
much of everything it reminds me
perfectly of that because it's
absolutely absurd absurd is another
great way to say it it's
absurd it's completely absurd it's
extremely
unpredictable it's super
chaotic
yeah because it's so free it can't be
predicted or can't be
ordered it's just too
free boxing air is not
possible or boxing the ocean it's just
not
possible
[Music]
geez what is all of
this just
like what how is this
even what it's just so
miraculously perfect and
simple it's like
okay just like an absolute unknowing
okay an absolute no
wning no
thinging every W and
everying a non-locality a nonp
positionality a non
orientability
okay
okay unbelievably simple so
what basic needs
infrastructures play have
fun laugh be
silly
enjoy eat well drink well be
merry [__] real good uh uh uh
bang it
up get all those
good
[__] eating
out an
no
three
sums gang
bangs glory
holes come shots
[Music]
orgasms all the good sex all the good
food all the good good music drinks play
Dance it's just endless
joy and basic
needs
Freedom just
Freedom just Freedom that's
already there's nowhere to go but this
Freedom this
Freedom that's
already here
now forever has never
left has never moved but is appearing to
[Music]
move it's just
too too
simple it's too simple and it has
nothing to do with knowing it just has
everything to do with no
thing oh boy oh boy oh
boy and there's no one that gets to know
no
thing nobody gets to earn no as an
attainment
what's left is just the ineffable hole
that's
it it's just the mystery everything
thinging
non-locally it's always been that way
there's never been a you there's never
been a me there's never been an
individual there's only been the whole
as long as there's an individual as long
as there's a me as long as there's that
Center Point it's always going to be War
conflict violence more for me less for
you [__] your
people but as long as that Center Point
is seen through by No One by nothing
that it's already made of then it's
dawing it's effortless basic needs fun
play everything
imaginable
feel like this is this is such a a a
broken record which is so
funny it's just the same it's just the
absolute same it's like you can't go
anywhere from here it's just simply this
and it's always and
already and is unconditionally
free and it's always
whole
and it's
dawing and when there's that contraction
there's meing
apparently
so it's just
nothing just it's
just
okay there's
nowhere there's just
nowhere there's nowhere everywhere
in all right I'm going to take a little
bit better
rest I'll probably stream
again
tomorrow we'll see on on what
topic it's good to get
the the
already
one
got some interesting ones coming
up all right
cool we'll see we'll
see there we
go all right thanks for tuning
in much
love this non-local
no
thingness
already
free
[Music]
already
free always and
free oh
[Music]
free
all
already
free sing with me
[Music]
all
free
all free
[Music]
all
free
free all
ready
free all ready
free
for